WE WILL CALL THE.
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE TO ORDER.
AND.
WISH EVERYONE A HAPPY NEW YEAR
AND WELCOME BACK.
AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH ITEM TO.
.
A V. EIGHT OH NINE IF THE
AUTHORS HERE.
CHOOSE ME.
WILL HAVE THE.
.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MEDINA PRESENT BAKER.
ARAMBULA.
BLOOM SCHABAS.
IRWIN.
KILEY.
LEVINE LOW PATTERSON QUIRK
SILVA.
YOU'RE.
SANTIAGO WEBER.
QUORUM IS PRESENT.
AND MISS QUICKSILVER YOU MAY
BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND HAPPY NEW YEAR TO
EVERYBODY.
TIME HAPPY TO PRESENT TODAY AB
EIGHT ZERO NINE AND AS I'VE BEEN
ON THIS COMMITTEE I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE HEARD ABOUT PRIORITY
LEGISLATION BEFORE. THIS
PARTICULAR. LEGISLATION WOULD
FOCUS ON MEMBERS AND FORMER
MEMBERS OF THE U. S.. ARMED
FORCES AND STATE MILITARY
RESERVE IN CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
UP FOR PRIORITY REGISTRATION
REGARDING NURSING PROGRAMS LIKE
IN MY DISTRICT AONE CYPRESS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHICH IS NOW
RANKED AS THE. NUMBER ONE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THAT THEY HAVE
A NURSERY NURSING PROGRAM.
THAT HAS BEEN IMPACTED.
WHICH IN MANY WAYS. IS A
TESTAMENT TO PEOPLE WANTING TO
GET INTO THIS TYPE OF PROFESSION
BUT BECAUSE OF IT BEING IMPACTED
WE HAVE MANY OF OUR STUDENTS
THEN GOING. TO OTHER PRIVATE
SCHOOLS WHICH ARE ALSO VERY WELL
ATTENDED BUT AS FAR IS OUR
VETERANS WE KNOW THAT THEIR
SERVICE IN THE MILITARY HAS NOT
ONLY. ALLOWED THEM TO ALREADY
EXPERIENCE AND TO PERFORM SOME
OF THE NURSING DUTIES AYE THAT
MANY OF OUR.
YOUNG CANDIDATES ARE LEARNING
ON THE U. S. B..
BUREAU OF LABOR STATS PROJECTS
THAT THE EMPLOYMENT OF
REGISTERED NURSES WILL GROW FROM
NINETEEN PERCENT BY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO COMPARED WITH ONLY
ELEVEN PERCENT FOR OCCUPATIONS
OVER ALL. AND AMERICA IN AMERICA
THERE ARE MILLIONS OF VETERANS
WHO PREVIOUSLY SERVED IN THE. U.
S. ARMED FORCES THAT POSSESS
MILITARY OCCUPATION SERVICE
TRAINING. MEDICS AND CORPSE MEN
WHO'VE SERVED IN THE MILITARY
ARE A CUSTOM AND WELL SUITED TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY MEDICAL CARE
IN DIVERSE SETTINGS MANY HAVE
RENDERED EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TREATMENT ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
SERVED AS SURGICAL TECHNICIANS
IN THE OPERATING ROOM FILLED
PRESCRIPTIONS IN THE PHARMACY OR
INDEPENDENTLY PERFORM PATIENT
CARE AT REMOTELY LOCATED. DUTY
STATIONS WHERE NO OTHER HEALTH
CARE. PROFESSIONALS EXIST BY
ALLOWING PRIORITY REGISTRATION
IN NURSING PROGRAMS FOR THIS
POPULATION CALIFORNIA COULD
CAPITALIZE ON THE PRIOR
EDUCATION EXPERIENCE AND SKILLS
POSSESSED BY SOME VETERAN
MILITARY PERSON NOW. AND
SIGNIFICANTLY AND SIGNIFICANT
GONNA LAY REDUCE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CONTINUING NURSING
SHORTAGE WHICH.
SO WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AGAIN AND NOTING AYE
THEIR EXPERIENCE HOT THAT'S COME
FIRST. HAND AND VERY DIVERSE
SCENARIOS.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
A.
DíAS.
THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SCUTTLED JUST. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
FOR THE MOTION BEFORE IS IS DUE
PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. OF MADAM SECRETARY
VIEWED CALL THE ROLL.
MEDINA AYE AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE SCHABAS.
CHáVEZ AYE IRWIN. IRWIN AYE
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LOW.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA AYE
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER A I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK IF I COULD BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR. OF COURSE.
THANK YOU.
THE VOTE IS NINE ZERO YOUR BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU MEMBERS.
WE'LL GO TO ITEM FOR A BI TWELVE
THIRTY ONE.
DR WEB
.
THAT AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS AFTERNOON I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
TWELVE THIRTY ONE THE BILL
RELATING TO THE STRUCTURE OF
SALARIES FOR C. ISSUE EMPLOYEES.
EVIDENCE STRONGLY SUGGESTS THE
C. ISSUE IS THE ONLY CALIFORNIA
STATE AGENCY THAT DOES NOT
PROVIDE SALLY STEPS TO ADD
STAFF.
THIS CREATES AN INVERSION IN
SAUDI SQUARED NEW HIRES ARE
EARNING MORE THAN MORE
EXPERIENCED EMPLOYEES.
FOLLOWING THE NINETEEN NINETY
SIX IMPASSE IN CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS MISSY ISSUE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES UNILATERALLY
ELIMINATED EXISTING EMPLOYEE
SALARIES STEPS.
INCREASES TIED TO JOB
PERFORMANCE AND LONGEVITY.
THIS IS RESULTED IN NEW HIRES
EARNING HIGHER SALARIES THAN
EXISTING EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE
WORKED IN THE SAME
CLASSIFICATION FOR MANY YEARS.
THIS INEQUITY HAS CREATED A
NINETEEN NINE A NINETY FIVE.
NINETY FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN VERSION GAP BETWEEN
THE SAUDIS OF NEWLY HIRED AND
LONG EMPLOYED AND LONG EMPLOYED
SEE ISSUE STE.
STAFF.
FOR TWO DECADES THE C. ISSUE HAS
BEEN UNWILLING TO REINSTATE
SALARY STEPS DESPITE THE FAILURE
OF THE EXISTING SAU STRUCTURE
AND THE INABILITY OF EMPLOYEES
TO EARN A FAIR AND EQUITABLE
WAIT.
AB THIRTEEN TWELVE THIRTY ONE
WILLIE REINSTATE THE FIVE
PERCENT SAUDI STICKS FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SUPPORT STAFF.
THE INCREASE WILL BE MADE
ANNUALLY ONE EMPLOYEE MEETS THE
STANDARDS WAS SATISFACTORY
PERFORMANCE AS DETERMINED BY THE
EMPLOYEES ADMINISTRATIVE.
HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF AB
TWELVE THIRTY ONE IS TERRY
WILSON WHO WORKS AT FRESNO STATE
UNIVERSITY AND PETE BLOUSE FROM
TO SEE ISSUE SAN MARCOS.
HI MY NAME IS PETE ROUND OF WORK
ETHIC AT CAL STATE SAN MARCUS
FOR ABOUT TWELVE YEARS.
AND DESPITE PROMISES MADE FROM
THE CSU THAT I WOULD MOVE
THROUGH THE SALARY RANGE OF MY
POSITION.
AND EVEN THOUGH I'VE RECEIVED
POSITIVE JOB EVALUATIONS MY
SALARY IS STAGNANT.
NEW EMPLOYEES ARE HIRED AT A
GREATER SALARY THAN MINE.
AND EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE HIRED
TO DO THE SAME WORK THIS
INEQUITY IS BECAUSE BY A CSU
SALARY STRUCTURE THAT IS CLEARLY
BROKEN.
WE NEED TO RETURN TO THE TIME
WHEN CSU STAFF RECEIVED OUR
STEPS LIKE EVERY OTHER STATE
EMPLOYEES OUR STATE AGENCY
RATHER.
I AM I AM ASKING FOR PARITY WITH
OTHER STATE AGENCIES I'M ASKING
TO BE FAIRLY COMPENSATED AND I'M
ASKING TO BE TREATED WITH
RESPECT.
AFTER THE CSU ELIMINATES OUR
STEPS IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX WE
TRIED TO REINSTATE STEP. BUT
CS YOU REFUSED.
AS A RESULT OUR SALARIES BECAME
UNEQUAL AND MANY EMPLOYEES ARE
LEAVING THE CSU FOR JOBS WITH
OTHER STATE AGENCIES.
IRONICALLY CSU ADMINISTRATORS
RECEIVE FIVE PERCENT ANNUAL
SORRY INCREASES ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
BUT NOT SUPPORTS THE.
WHILE EMPLOYEE SALARIES REMAINED
STAGNANT AND THE CS YOU CLAIMS
POVERTY. THE CSU PROFITED BY
INCREASING THE ACCOUNTS IT HOLDS
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE TREASURY BY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
WHICH GENERATES HUNDREDS OF
MILLION DOLLARS EXCUSE ME
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN INTEREST.
THE CSU PROFITED BY NOT PUTTING
AN EQUITABLE SALARIES AND NOW
IT'S TIME TO FILL THE CSU
ACCOUNTABLE BY COMPLYING WITH
THE SAME PRACTICES ALL OTHER
STATE AGENCIES.
I'M NOT APPRECIATED IF YOU'D
SUPPORT AB TWELVE THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEDINA MEMBERS.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY NEW YEAR.
MY NAME'S TERRY WILSON A NUMBER
TEN YOUR EMPLOYEE AT FRESNO
STATE UNIVERSITY.
AB TWELVE THIRTY ONE RE INSTATE
SALARY STEPS THAT WERE
UNILATERALLY TAKEN AWAY BY THE
CSU ADMINISTRATION TWENTY YEARS
AGO.
FOR TWENTY YEARS THE CITY HAS
YOUR HAS BEEN UNWILLING TO
REINSTATE SALARY STEPS
DESPITE THE FAILURE OF THE
EXISTING SALARY STRUCTURE. AND
THE INABILITY OF EMPLOYEES TO
EARN A FAIR AND EQUITABLE WAGE.
ALL WE ARE ASKING FOR IS PARITY.
WITH OTHER STATE AGENCIES AND
PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYEES.
I WAS FIRST HIRED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN AND AS
ADMINISTRATIVE ANALYST
SPECIALIST AT FRESNO STATE.
I WORKED IN THE ENGINEERING
DEPARTMENT I OVERSAW STAFF AND
THE BUDGET.
I WAS PROMOTED TO THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR STUDENT AFFAIRS
OFFICE.
WHICH REQUIRED INCREASE STAFF
RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND MORE OVERSIGHT.
AND BUDGET RESPONSIBILITIES.
I NOW RUN THE BULLDOG ID CARD
AND IMAGING DEPARTMENT AT FRESNO
STATE WE EMPLOY THIRTEEN
EMPLOYEES WORKING DIRECTLY UNDER
ME.
I ALSO PRIDE ASSISTANCE TO THE
VICE PRESIDENT FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES.
THE CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER AND
THE UNIVERSITY CONTROLLER.
DESPITE THESE CHANGES IN MY JOB
RESPONSIBILITIES AND WORKLOAD.
AND DESPITE CONSISTENTLY
RECEIVING OUTSTANDING.
EVALUATIONS FOR MY PERFORMANCE.
MY BASE SALARY HAS NOT INCREASED
IN TEN YEARS.
AS I WORK THE FRESNO STATE.
ADDING FURTHER INSULT NEW
EMPLOYEES ARE BEING HIRED. IN
THE SAME JOB CLASSIFICATION THAT
I WORK IN.
AND EARNING A HIGHER SALARY THAN
I.
THIS IS YOUR ADMINISTRATION HAS
ADMITTED THAT THE EXISTING STAFF
SALARY STRUCTURE IS BROKEN.
IN FACT IT WOULD TAKE NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE THE SAME HIGH SALARIES
TO LONG TERM EMPLOYEES.
THAT ALREADY BEEN GIVEN TO NEW
HIRES.
I HAVE REMAINED STAGNANT IN MY
JOB.
AND SEE IF YOU ADMINISTRATORS
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE NNUAL
SALARY INCREASES.
EVEN WHEN THEY AREN'T EVALUATED
FOR THEIR JOBS.
AND THIS WAS A FACT PROVEN AND
CONFIRMED IN LAST YEAR'S.
AUDIT BY THE STATE REVIEWING CSU
SALARY PRACTICES.
THE AUDIT ALSO FOUND THAT CSU
MANAGEMENT POSITIONS GREW AT
OVER TWICE THE RATE OF SUPPORT
STAFF.
WITH HALF A BILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR TOTAL COMPENSATION.
THAT FAR OUTPACE THE SALARY.
INCREASES OF OUR SUPPORT STAFF.
AGAIN WHAT WE ARE ASKING FOR
HERE IS PARITY WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES.
AND THEIR EMPLOYEES.
AYE SHOULDN'T BE PENALIZED FOR
WORKING AT THE CSU. NOR SHOULD
NEW EMPLOYEES BE HIRED FOR THE
SAME JOB CLASSIFICATION BE GIVEN
A HIGHER SALARY.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB TWELVE
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WAS SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
WHERE PROUD TO JOIN AS A CO
SPONSOR WE THINK THAT THIS IS A
LONG AWAITED AND JUST FIX THINK
YOU.
BRIAN HOW WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SYLVIA SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF OF
THE TWENTY THOUSAND MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
YOUR SUPPORT.
TIM CAMERA BEHALF OF SEIU LOCAL
ONE THOUSAND ALSO HERE IN
SUPPORT.
PAT GAP PRESIDENT SEE ISSUE
EMPLOYEES UNION THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS CAL STATE UNIVERSITY CHICO
AND FULL SUPPORT.
MARK MCKINNEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION A
STRONG SUPPORT.
CAPTAIN HUTCHINSON BODY
TECHNICIAN IT'S ISSUE TEN
ISLANDS IN SUPPORT.
THE CHEMICAL OUT PLOY AT CSU
FULLERTON I BEEN WITH THIS ISSUE
FOR THIRTY FOUR YEARS STRONG
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGILE MARTINEZ
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. BOBBY RAHAL WE ARE
OPPOSED THE MEASURE.
I WE'RE POSE FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS ONE.
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THIS
WOULD IMPACT A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT PROCESS.
AND WHILE I WAS NOT EMPLOYEES.
OF THE CSU NINETEEN NINETY SIX
ARE.
I DO BELIEVE.
HISTORICALLY THE WAY THIS
PARTICULAR POT OF MONEY WAS
FUNDED.
WAS BY ALLOTMENT FROM THE STATE.
THAT HAD TO GO AWAY DURING THE
BUDGET CRISIS.
DURING THE NINETIES.
AT THAT POINT. I WAS CHOSEN
UNITS.
THAT MADE THE DECISION TO ASK
WOULD ASK TRADING HOUSES TO
RESCIND THAT ACTION.
WE ARE COURSE DO BELIEVE THAT
THERE HAS TO BE REINVESTMENT IN
OUR EMPLOYEES.
I THINK THAT IS MERITED IN THE
FACT THAT WE'VE HAD TODAY TEN
PERCENT SALARY CREASE FROM TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
AND THEN AGAIN WE JUST SUPPORTED
EIGHTY NINE PERCENT SELLER
CREASE.
LITTLE GOLF ACT OF SEVENTEEN
THROUGH.
TWENTY TWENTY NOW BEYOND. ABOUT
A FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IT COST%
THE SYSTEM TO IMPLEMENT AVERELL
SUPPLY THAT TO SEE IF A AS WELL
AFFECT ASSOCIATION.
SO WE AGREE WITH THE DESIRE TO
ENSURE THE STRINGS THESE
APPOINTEES ARE COMPENSATED
APPROPRIATELY.
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE COST
OF THIS BILL HAVE.
GOING FORWARD ONGOING WITHOUT
ANY SORT INVEST FOR THE STATE TO
OFFSET THAT.
STRUCTURE. NOW WHEN IT COMES TO
THE GUY ON THE PHONE THAT WAS
REFERRED TO THAT COULD BE TAPPED
INTO.
PER STATE LAW.
THOSE FUNDS IN THE REVENUE THAT
ARE COLLECTED NO ARE REQUIRED TO
BE USE FOR COUPLE FACILITY USES.
ONE TIME.
SO THERE THE AS THE LAW AS LET'S
ADDRESS FOR AS.
STARTED THAT IS THE PURPOSE OF
THOSE FUNDS AND HOW MAY BE USED
FOR SOME W. MUST BE OPPOSED.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
MR WENT.
THANK YOU.
MR MEDINA AND I I AM GOING TO
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT
PARITY THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
AND.
AND ALSO THE FACT THAT LONGTIME
EMPLOYEES ARE ACTUALLY EARNING
LESS THAN.
NEW EMPLOYEES AT THE SAME RANGE
SO LIKE I SAID I I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL THAT I AM
CONCERNED WITH PUTTING THIS INTO
STATUE AND PUTTING THE AMOUNT
INTO STATUTE TO.
I THINK THESE.
.
THE SORT OF DECISION SHOULD BE
MADE AT THE BARGAINING TABLE
AND.
BUT I UNDERSTAND YOU'VE BEEN
WAITING FOR. A DECADE TO GET
THAT DONE AND.
AND THAT CERTAINLY MAKES THAT
MAKES THINGS MUCH MORE.
DIFFICULT AND AND I THINK THAT
DOES.
.
REQUIRE THE LEGISLATURE TO TO
MAKE THAT STEP SELF. A AGAIN
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL THAT
WE NEED TO BE WARY ABOUT THE.
LOSS OF BUDGET FLEXIBILITY IN A
DOWNTURN.
THIS BAKER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'M. JUST AT.
TRY TO UNDERSTAND IF I RECALL IN
THE FALL THERE'D BEEN AN
AGREEMENT FOR AYE NINE PERCENT
PAY INCREASE OVER THREE YEARS
FIVE REMEMBER THAT QUICKLY.
DOES THAT COVER DIFFERENT.
EMPLOYEES ARE CLASSIFICATIONS
THIS ON TOP OF THAT NINE PERCENT
PAY INCREASE IF THIS PASSES WHAT
IS THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THAT
PAY INCREASE THAT I THINK WAS
PART OF COLOR
THE BARGAINING NEGOTIATIONS AND
THE S..
STEPPING INCREASES ARE DIFFERENT
THAN AND THEN MOVE THEN RAISES
IS WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
INCREASES STEPPING CREASES TALK
ABOUT HOW THE STRUCTURE OF THE
INSTITUTION EXIST.
THE PEOPLE ENTER AT A CERTAIN
LEVEL IF THEY'RE SUCCESSFUL THEY
MOVE UP THE LADDER WITH BEEN
THEIR CLASSIFICATION WHEN YOU
GET A PAY INCREASE IT GOES
ACROSS THE BOARD. AND SO
EVERYBODY GETS THAT SO THIS
WOULD BE OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING
THAT PEOPLE WOULD GET BUT A STEP
INCREASE IT TALKS ABOUT HOW YOU
PROGRESS IN THE FIELD AND IN THE
AREA WHERE YOU ARE. WITHOUT A
STEP INCREASE EVERYTHING JUST
THIS KIND OF FLOAT AROUND IN
NEGOTIATING AMONG INDIVIDUALS
VERSUS UNDERSTANDING HOW YOU
MOVE UP THE LADDER. AND EVERY
OTHER STATE AGENCY HAS THAT
LATTER THAT'S DEVELOPED IN THE
STRUCTURE SO THAT WHEN WE IF
THEY IF THEY'RE AT STEP ONE THEY
GO TO THE GO TO THREE. AND IF
THE AGENCY OR THE STATE COMES
AND GIVES A FIVE PERCENT RAISE
ECHOES ACROSS THE BOARD BUT THE
STEPS REMAIN. IN PLACE AND SO IT
REALLY IS ABOUT HOW YOU DEVELOP
A CAREER PATTERN OR LATTER TO A
TOAST AS PEOPLE WORK IN A FIELD
AVAIL JUST REMAIN IN THE SAME
SALARY. AND THEN GET EVERYBODY
GETS IT INCREASE ITS TALK ABOUT
BASICALLY A STEP IN THE
PROFESSION AND MOVING UP WITHIN
THE CATEGORY WHICH RIGS YOU
EXIST.
WE HAVE THAT SYSTEM FOR MANY
MANY YEARS.
AND THEN IT WOULD AWAY A WE
HAVE PUT IN STACKS WHO NOW FOR
THE FACULTY TO HAVE STEP
INCREASES AGAIN A BECAUSE THAT
WAS TAKEN AWAY WHEN I WAS THERE
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT. OF THE
MORALE ISSUE IS VERY LOW WHEN IT
COMES TO NOT UNDERSTANDING THE
STRUCTURE OF THE INSTITUTION HOW
YOU MOVE IN AND HOW YOU MOVE UP
WITH AND CATEGORIES OF RIGHTS OR
WHATEVER IT MAY BE. BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT THE A RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU AND SO BASICALLY
THEY'RE CHEERING STEPPING
COLUMNS AND EXACTLY OKAY. AND SO
THIS IS ESSENTIALLY ON TOP OF A
NINE PERCENT PAY INCREASE THE
BABY HAS BEEN NEGOTIATED.
THROUGH COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
EXACTLY.
I HAVE THAT'S HELPFUL NOW I I
SHARE THE CONCERNS ARE GOOD
COLLEAGUE.
FOR VENTURA HAS.
BASICALLY MY NAME IN COMMITTEE.
MEMBER IRWIN IT'S LED ME TO A
DIFFERENT CONCLUSION BECAUSE I
JUST FIND IT IS SO RIGID AND I'M
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT REGIONALLY
MANDATING.
SOMETHING LIKE THIS WITH CS YOU
I I HOPE THAT THERE CAN BE A
PERSON I WOULD LIKE TO SEE AN
ALTERNATIVE ALLOWS NINE MORE
FLEXIBILITY BUT. THIS TO BE PART
OF THAT COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
PROCESS ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE
LAST COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
PROCESS LEAST THE WHEN THE FALL.
SHOWED THAT THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INCREASES.
AND THAT WHEN. THERE ARE TIMES
WHEN THERE ARE.
SUCCESSFULLY OBTAINED THROUGH
THAT VERY PROCESS.
BUT THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING
THAT FOR ME PRITCHETT. EMBASSY
WHO.
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA
MISTER CHAIR.
.
YOU KNOW WHEN I FIRST SAW THIS
BILL I DID I THOUGHT OKAY I WANT
TO GIVE PEOPLE A RAISE LIKE
THINGS ARE GOOD WE SHOULD BE
GIVING RAISES.
AND THEN I SAW THAT THE LAST
TIME THIS BILL CAME UP I VOTED
NO. AND I THOUGHT WELL WHY ON
EARTH WOULD I HAVE VOTED NO AND
I I LOOKED AT THE BILL LITTLE
THAT MORE CLOSELY. AND.
.
NO I SEE.
FIRST SO THAT YOU DIDN'T GO
SHE'D AN INCREASE.
UNDER THE CURRENT SYSTEM.
AND SO THAT THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS WORKED.
YOU WILL GET MORE MONEY YOU'RE
ALSO GOING TO BE GETTING A SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLAR BONUS.
WHICH AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS ON
IT'S NEVER ENOUGH.
I DON'T SEE THAT A NEGATIVE WAY
WE GO TO WORK BECAUSE WE WANT TO
FEEL PURPOSE IN THE WORK THAT WE
DO. WE ALSO APPRECIATE A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE AND WE HOPE
TO HAVE MORE MONEY FOR NEXT YEAR
SO WE CAN PROVIDE FOR MORE SO WE
CAN BETTER OURSELVES AND OUR
LIVES. AND SO.
WE SHOULD ALWAYS BE LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO INCREASE THE PAY THAT
PEOPLE ARE GETTING.
AND AND AND OF COURSE TO PAY
PEOPLE WITH DIGNITY FOR THE
VALUE OF THEIR PROVIDING OF SIX
PARTICULARLY IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IN IN
THE CITY.
SYSTEM OF HIGHER EDUCATION HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
I THINK AYE AYE FUNDAMENTALLY IN
THE LAST TIME THAT I VOTED NO
HAD A PROBLEM WITH.
SIDESTEPPING THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS ONE THAT HAS
WORKED EFFECTIVELY
FOR YOU. AND ALSO.
A LACK OF.
UNDERSTANDING THE REPERCUSSIONS
YOUR INTERESTS AND I COMPLETELY
RESPECT.
YOUR INTERESTS ARE TO IMPROVE
THE LOT OF YOUR MEMBERSHIP.
AND AND TO PROFESSIONAL EYES THE
WORK THAT YOUR MEMBERSHIP DOES.
BUT.
BUT WHEN YOU ARE ENGAGING WITH
YOUR BARGAINING PARTNER.
THE TRUSTEES HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
OVERALL FISCAL HEALTH OF THE
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
AND OF A GREAT DEGREE OF
UNCERTAINTY.
THAT THE CSU FACE.
IF WE WERE TO GO AHEAD AND AY
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT ENOUGH
I WANT TO GIVE YOU MORE AND AND
I DO LIKE ON A PERSONAL LEVEL.
FOUNDED WE WOULD BE DOING THAT.
AT A TIME WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
AND YOU KNOW MOST YEARS DOES NOT
INVEST ENOUGH IN OUR SYSTEMS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION. AT A TIME WHEN
WE HAVE FOR YEARS NOT EVEN
PROVIDED ENOUGH SEATS FOR
STUDENTS THAT QUALIFY. TO GO TO
A CSU OR ANY OF THE OTHER
SYSTEMS.
AND I IN AN AIR OF UNCERTAINTY
WHERE WE HAVE AN ECONOMY.
WHERE WE'VE GOT A STOCK MARKET
ON STEROIDS AND FEDERAL FISCAL
POLICY IS GOING TO POP?
AND THE STATE'S BUDGET.
NEVER SURVIVES
THE ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
INELEGANT WAY IT'S WERE THICK
AND THE CUTS ARE AWFUL IT'S SO
NOT ONLY DO WE THEN. INCREASE
FEES ON STUDENTS
WE CUT. THE JOBS AVAILABLE TO
YOUR MEMBERS WE CUT NUMBER OF
INSTRUCTORS ON CAMPUSES.
IN WE CUT A LOT OF OTHER
CRITICAL SERVICES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IT'S DIRE
AND SO. WE ARE AT THIS.
DANGEROUS PEAK.
FOR OUR STATE BUDGET.
THAT I CAN SEE OVER THE OTHER
SIDE.
AND IT GOES DOWN
IT DOESN'T KEEP GOING UP.
AND.
AND AND THAT IS WHAT. WILL.
STOP ME AS IT DID LAST TIME
FROM VOTING YES ON THIS AGAIN AS
AS MUCH AS I PERSONALLY. BELIEVE
IN BETTERING THE SITUATION OF
YOUR MEMBERS AND AND GIVING OUT
MORE MONEY.
.
WE WE ARE NOT IN A PLACE OUTSIDE
AS MUCH AS WE THINK THAT WE ARE.
TO ACTUALLY MAKE THIS LONG TERM
THAT THAT WE CAN SUSTAIN THE
TYPE OF INCREASE THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR AND AGAIN COMPLETELY
RESPECT THE BILL THE AUTHOR AND
WHAT YOU GUYS ARE TRYING TO DO.
AND I'M SORRY THAT I CANNOT
SUPPORT TODAY.
MR JOBS.
A VERY MUCH I YOU HAD SPENT A
LOT TIME LOOKING AT THIS.
IN.
MY PREVIOUS LIFE.
OF.
THERE STEP PROCESS IS FOLLOWED
IN THE.
AND THE DEPARTMENT IN FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ALL THE TIME.
PEOPLE COME AT A CERTAIN LEVEL.
AND THE MILITARY GOOD.
DOD THEIR.
GS LEVELS THREE FOUR FIVE SIX
SEVEN EIGHT NINE.
AND YOU HAVE STEPS WITHIN THEM
INSTEAD FOR DESIGN.
AS A RECOGNITION.
BUT THE THAT'S WHERE TO SET A
PERSON HAS AT A CERTAIN JOBS OF
A JOB IS RATED. AND IT YEAR
SEVEN OR EIGHT.
THIS STEP RECOGNIZES LONGEVITY
THEIR.
SO THE QUESTION THE AUTHOR IS.
I BELIEVE IN DOD THE STEPS ARE.
TWO OR THREE YEARS YOU HAVE TO
BE IN A JOB BEFORE YOU REACH
OTHER STEP WHAT YOU'RE
ENVISIONING OF THIS.
IS THAT EVERYYEAR TO YEAR EVERY
THREE YEAR.
THAT YOU'D GO FOR THE STEP.
YOU'RE IN HERE JUST STEP
INCREASES BASED ON MERIT ANY
VALUATION RIGHT BUT WHEN WOULD
THAT COME FORWARD.
BUT PART.
A A MY UNDERSTANDING IS IT'S THE
ANNUAL IT USED TO BE ANNUAL.
THAT WAS ANNUAL INCREASES AND
THAT THAT WAS WHAT THE THAT'S
WHAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA THEIR
ANNUAL INCREASES BUT THEY'RE
BASED STRICTLY UPON MERIT. THAT
YOU HAVE TO HAVE POSITIVE
EVALUATION GOOD EVALUATION TO
MOVE TO THE NEXT STEP PROVINCE
WE GET TO THE TOP OF THE LADDER
OBVIOUSLY AS YOU KNOW AND THEN
AT THAT POINT YOU HAVE TO. DO
SOMETHING EXTRAORDINARY TO VOTE
TOOK TO TRANSITION TO THE NEXT
LEVEL OF ANOTHER NET ALLOW THEM
POSSIBLE LETTER WHEN SHE REACHED
THE TOP. BUT.
BUT IT'S SIMILAR TO THE FITS
GIVE OFFENSE RIVER TWO YEARS THE
STATE DOES IT EVERY YEAR OKAY
IT'S EVERY YEAR BASED ON MERIT
IN A REQUIRES AN EVALUATION BY
OTHER.
BY THEIR SENIOR TO GIVE THEM A
FAVOR VALUATION THAT PLACE UP
MIA AND THAT'S A STEP IN NOW. AS
FAR AS I HAVE A LETTER HERE THE
SAME ONE THAT THE.
.
DID YOU MENTIONED EARLIER AS FAR
AS A NINE PERCENT OVER THREE
YEARS WAS TWO PERCENT A YEAR
WHOM THE.
.
QUESTION DIRECTLY MORE TO YOU
SIR.
IS.
.
PUTTING THE NINE PERCENT BECAUSE
THAT'S SOMETHING NEGOTIATED WITH
DEALS WITH.
BUDGET AND ECONOMICS AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT WORKED ENTERED INTO
THIS WHICH I THINK IS SOMETHING
SEPARATE FROM THE STEP. IS THIS
TO ME IS A.
AND HR MANAGEMENT POSITION THAT
YOU HIRE PEOPLE COMING NEXT FOR
TEACHER. IMPROVEMENTS SO REWARD
THEM FOR THEIR EXPERIENCE AFTER
A TRIAL VALUATION.
YOU DON'T HAVE THAT NOW.
I THINK IT IS STRICTLY FROM THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AN INDIVIDUAL
RECOGNIZING THEIR EXPERTISE
IT'S BASED ON WHAT THE FUNDING
IS RIGHT IN THE BUDGET YEAR TO
YEAR.
THAT TO YOU YOUR ARGUMENT WOULD
BE SUPPORTING WHAT WAS
DISCUSSED EARLIER ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
WHICH IS SEPARATE FROM
RECOGNIZING HOW DO YOU DEVELOP A
WORKFORCE TO WELL PROVIDE THE
EXPERTISE THAT'S REQUIRED IN IN
RUNNING THE. DNC TWO SHIFTS WALL
AGAIN THIS IS THIS HAS AS MUCH
OF ANALYSIS AND BY THOSE THE
PROPONENTS IS BEEN IN THE PLACE
FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS NOW THIS.
IS THAT WHAT THE PROCEDURE IS.
.
IF THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS.
DESIRED AS PART OF THE
NEGOTIATION PROCESS THE
CLUTTERED MARKET PROCESS IF A
STEP IS THE WAY TO GO THAT I
THINK.
FRANKLY THAT'S SHOULD BE
NEGOTIATED OUT THE TABLE AND
SHOULD BE.
TAKEN AWAY.
SHOULD BE PART THE GIVE AND
TAKE IS PARTLY GESTATION
PROCESS.
AND WHEN WE DO HAVE FUNDS
AVAILABLE FOR A MERIT STEP
INCREASE SPEED PRIDE IN THE
BUDGET WE DO PROVIDE THAT YOU'RE
HERE.
BUT A FORMULA BE SOMETHING THAT
WE DON'T HAVE THAT PER SE WE
DON'T HAVE ALLOTMENT. IN THE
BUDGET YEAR TO YEAR.
BUT YOU SEE THE DIFFERENCE
BECAUSE.
PAY.
THE DIM NEGOTIATE THREE PERCENT
A YEAR IS FOR THREE YEARS NOW
ABSENT. THAT'S RIGHT LOOKING AT
THE ECONOMIC REALITY OF THE
INSTITUTION IN ITS ENTIRETY.
STEP.
IS DESIGNED TO LOOK AT THE
INDIVIDUAL IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
EXPERTISE AND THE JOB TO DO AND
IT'S MORE OF AN H. R..
SYSTEM TO.
SO THAT PEOPLE PRODUCE BETTER
DATE THESE SEE AN UPWARD
MOBILITY THEY LEARN NEW SKILLS
TO DO BETTER THAT'S DIFFERENT
AND PAIN PEOPLE DON THE ECONOMY
IT'S LOOK AT. HOW DO YOU MANAGE
YOUR WORKFORCE
SO ARE YOU TELLING ME THAT THE
CEO S. SYSTEM? THE WAY YOU
MANAGE A REWARD YOUR WORKFORCE
HISTORICALLY. ON THE PERCENT
INCREASE NOT ON THE OF VALUATION
AND PERFORMANCE.
BECAUSE THOSE ARE TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS IS THAT WE ARE TELLING
ME.
I THINK THAT THE THE SALARY
CHRIS THEY WOODS RECEIVED BY THE
GROUP IS ALSO THERE AS
AMERICA'S.
THERE'S A VALUATION OF AS WELL
SO THREE PERCENT. IS NOT I'M
SORRY I APOLOGIZE.
I'M. I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER FOR
YOU CANNOT GET OUT TO GO THIS
WAY TONIGHT. I'VE LET THE PUBLIC
KNOW I WENT OUT OF MY WAY TODAY
WHEN I HEARD ABOUT THIS TO
CONTACT THE PRESIDENT.
OF.
THE STATE COLLEGE IN MY AREA.
WOULDN'T. DON'T GET A RESPONSE
BUT I GOT THIS LETTER AND I READ
THE LETTER AND IT DEALS WITH
SOMETHING TOTALLY DIFFERENT I'M
LOOKING AT MORE OF THE.
HR PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT OF
A.
OF A STATE EMPLOYEE WHICH IS
SEPARATE FROM.
THE INCREASE ON THE ECONOMY
THOSE ARE TWO DIFFERENT THINGS.
HAVING WORKED IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT FOR THIRTY YEARS.
IF WHAT YOU DIDN'T TELL ME THAT
I'M GOING TO.
LANE MORE SUPPORTIVE YOUR BILL
TO GET OUT THE COMMITTEE
UNDERSTANDING THOUGH THAT I'M
GONNA CONTINUE TO RESEARCHERS
AND RESERVE THE RIGHT. ON THE
FLORIDA POP TO GO THE OTHER WAY
BUT. I'M OF CONCERN THAT.
WE HAVE LEADERS IN THIS STATE.
THAT DON'T RECOGNIZE THAT THE
MOST IMPORTANT COMMODITY THEY
HAVE IS A WORKFORCE.
AND THAT YOU NEED TO HAVE A FAIR
AND EQUITABLE SYSTEM.
TO ENSURE THEIR UP PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND STEP HAS BEEN
DOING THAT. ARE IN THE FEDERAL
AND STATE INSTITUTIONS EVER
SINCE I'VE BEEN WATCHING THIS
THING SO I GUESS I WOULD STEP
BACK AND SAY. THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO PAY FOR MORE OF.
THE OPERATIONS OUT OF OUR BASE
BUDGET.
WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO DO MORE
WITH WHAT WE GET FROM THE STATE.
AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE CSU
AND REVENUE THAT SUPPORTS THE
INSTITUTION.
IT IS GOING TO BE FOR.
STUDENTS AND FROM THE GENERAL
FUND THERE IS NO OTHER SOURCE OF
FUNDING AVAILABLE.
AND SO WE HAVE FROZEN R. FEES
FOR OVER THE LAST SIX YEARS WE
JUST DID INCREASE LAST YEAR.
WE HAVE BEEN GETTING A LOT
MEANS FROM THE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE IN FROM THE GOVERNOR
TO INCREASE THEY AUGMENTATION
BUT THAT'S JUST. THAT'S JUST
BARELY KEEPING UP WITH WHAT
REFLATION THIS SO ANY INCREASE
IN SALARY COMPENSATION. NEEDS TO
REVIVE IT AS PART OF THAT BASE
FOR THE FUNDING IN THE BUDGET.
ARE HAS THE APPROPRIATE BASED ON
A STUDENT ASSESSMENT ON HE'S.
THERE IS NO OTHER SOURCE OF
FUNDING AVAILABLE AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT ARGUMENT ALSO
BUT. I WOULD GO BACK TO SAY
HAVING RAN ORGANIZATION LIKE
THIS MYSELF.
WHEN YOU INVESTING YOUR PEOPLE
AND RECOGNIZE OUR PERFORMANCE
STEP YOU OFTEN FIND. THE SAME
WORKERS ARE GONNA FIND SAVINGS
AND EFFICIENCIES AND HOW TO RUN
YOUR ORGANIZATION.
NOW IT FOUR YEARS AGO WE
REQUESTED.
THAT THE C. ISSUES.
CONDUCT AND ACTIVITY BASED
COSTING TO LOOK AND SEE HOW THEY
CAN BE MORE EFFICIENT AS AN
INSTITUTION.
AND THESE EXACT PEOPLE WHO WHO
DO WE ARE TRAINED TO DO THIS
WOULD BE THE ONE TO TELL YOU HOW
TO FIND EFFICIENCY.
TO ME THAT WOULD BE A BETTER
ARGUMENT THAN FIGURING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO JUST TAKE IT SO
MUCH MONEY IT'S GOING TO PACK
THE STUDENTS FOR. TO ME THAT'S A
DIFFERENT ARGUMENT THIS IS MORE
OF AN HR ISSUE.
SO AS I SAID EARLIER IF.
YOU KNOW WE GOT SOMETIME BEFORE
IT'S GONNA BE ON THE FLOOR BUT
AS A.
SOMEBODY IS WHERE THE SYSTEM.
AND HONORED STANDING DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN STEP IN HR RELATIONSHIPS
AND UNDERSTANDING MAKING BUDGETS
THOSE ARE TWO DIFFERENT THINGS.
OKAY THEY DO COME ALIVE BUT
THEY'RE TWO DIFFERENT THINGS AND
THAT AND AND THAT'S WHY.
KAREN HANGS A PRESIDENT CAL
STATE SAN MARCOS IN THE HIVE IN
THE HIVE WHITE ALL THESE GUYS
GETPAID THE BIG BUCKS TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO MAKE THIS WORK.
SO AS I SAID I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS.
HE GOT REPUBLICANS BOY NAY ON
THIS THING ABOUT THAT.
BUT I'M GOING TO ALSO.
WAIT UNTIL ICE YOU COME ACROSS
THE FLOOR.
IF I HAVE SO MANY CAN GET TO
MUNICH SPYING TO ME. HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO TAKE CARE ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE WORKING FOR STATE AND
HAVE SOMEBODY WORK IN THE SAME
POSITION?
FOR TEN YEARS.
AND NEVER BE INCREASED AS PAY.
TO ME IS.
ROTH.
AND I HAD HAD SOMETHING TO THAT.
I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER QUICK SO
IT.
YOU YOU AND IT. O. I I GET
DURING MY PROGRESSION AS I
PROGRESSED THROUGH THE SERIES.
I HAVE THREE.
UNDERGRADS IN MATHEMATICS
SCIENCE AND BIOLOGY AND AS I
PROGRESSED THROUGH THE CSU. I
PICKED UP AN MBA I PICKED OF A
MASTERS IN INTERNATIONAL
MANAGEMENT EVERYTHING THEY ASKED
ME TO DO. TO HELP OUT WITH THE
RUNNING THE SYSTEM HELPING OUT
MY ACCOUNTING DEPARTMENT.
PAID OUT OF MY OWN POCKET
HOWEVER.
HE STAYED THE SAME.
THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO.
THINK MISTER TURNOUT LOOK AT
THIS BILL FROM FROM A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE AYE I ONCE WAS THE
PRESENT A LARGE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT.
IN THE U. S. AND. WE WE ALSO
RAN TO THE SIMILAR PROBLEMS.
SORRY.
A SOLID STEP SCALE AND A
CONSISTENT NUMBER ACTUALLY HOPES
INSTITUTION IN A NUMBER OF WAYS.
NUMBER ONE ITS LONG TERM BUDGET
PLAN.
NUMBER TWO WHICH WE FOUND OUT
AT THE TIME WERE DEFICIENT AND
HAVING SUPERVISORS.
ACTUALLY DO EVALUATIONS FOLLOW
THROUGH.
EXCITED BECAUSE OFTENTIMES IN
THESE LARGE INSTITUTIONS.
I'M NOT AN EXPERT OF YOUR
INSTITUTION BUT I CAN TELL YOU
WHERE WE WERE AT. THE A ONE OF
THE PLANS WE HAD.
WAS THAT WOULD THE MANAGEMENT
WAS NOT DOING EVALUATIONS.
AND THEREFORE BREEZES ONE
HAPPENING AND THEREFORE
PREDICTED HE WAS A LITTLE BIT
LOWER TO.
BUT IT ALSO FORCES AN
INSTITUTION TO DO DO SALLY
SURVEYS RIGHT BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHETHER WHAT
INST OTHER INSTITUTIONS ARE
PAYING.
AND IN THAT HELPS TO RETAIN
EMPLOYEES NOW.
I WILL SAY THIS BILL TO.
THERE ARE TOOLS IN AN
INSTITUTION HAS EVEN IF THIS WAS
SET IN STONE.
OF THAT COULD BE OFF RAMPS THE
TOUGH BUDGET TIMES BECAUSE WE
LOOKED AT THAT AS WELL RIGHT
THERE'S. IN CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS YOU CAN GO TIME AND
MOTION STUDY THAT WOULD MAKE AN
ORGANIZATION MORE EFFICIENT.
AND THE INSTITUTION JUST HAS TO
BE CREATIVE ABOUT HOW ABOUT HOW
IT APPROACHES IT ITS CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS.
OTHERS ALSO LAYOFFS AND
FURLOUGHS I MEAN THAT THERE'S A
NUMBER OF THINGS IN AN
INSTITUTION CAN DO THAT ARE THAT
ARE.
MAYBE NOT POPULAR TO THE FOLK
FROM THE STABLE BUT THERE ARE
OFFERING AMPS UP THE BUDGET. THE
BUDGET DECLINES IN THE
LEGISLATURE'S DONE AND
INSTITUTIONS THAT I KNOW BECAUSE
I WAS IN A PLACE WHERE WHO DO
ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT.
A LAYOFF SOME FURLOUGHS AT A
TIME WHEN WHEN WE WERE GOING
INTO A REALLY TOUGH UP BUDGET
SITUATIONS AT THE STATE. SO THAT
IS SO I JUST WANT CERTAINLY
PEOPLE TO OUR OFF RAMPS
ON AND THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY A
BAD A.
AND THINK THE I MEAN IT WE WILL
RUIN AN INSTITUTION. THERE ARE
THINGS IN THIS ISSUE CAN DO
AGAIN OP PRESS UPON THE
INSTITUTION AND LOVE THE LAST
pPOINT REALLY IS. FOLKS COME TO
THE LEGISLATURE.
.
AND SEEKTHE SORT OF SOLUTIONS
WHEN ALL ELSE FAILED.
I MEAN I I TRUST
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO ANSWER
THAT YOU WOULDN'T BE HERE IF A
CONTRACT IF THE BARGAINING TABLE
WASN'T WORKING. AND AND IF THIS
HAD BEEN A LONG TERM FIGHT THAT
THERE IS NO SOLUTION TO. HANDLE
THOSE ARE MY TWO CENTS.
.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
MISTER PATTERSON.
AS CHAIRMAN OF.
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THIS.
.
TERRY APPRECIATE YOU COMING.
AND I'M COMING AT THIS FROM.
.
LIFELONG RESIDENT FRESNO
CALIFORNIA FRESNO STATE GRAD AND
YOUR FRIEND.
NOW AND I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT YOU DO.
AND I PAID ATTENTION TO THE
DETAILS AT OUR UNIVERSITY.
WE ARE DOING SOME VERY
WONDERFUL THINGS AND I
APPRECIATE IT ALL.
BUT I'LL TELL YOU WHAT I THINK I
THINK.
I THINK I THINK OF THE SUPPORT
STAFFS ARE UNDERVALUED.
AND I THINK IT'S BEEN
DEMONSTRATED BY THE FACT THAT
YOU WANTED TO COME BACK TO THE
TABLE. YOU WANTED TO NEGOTIATE.
AND FRANKLY YOU ARE UNABLE TO DO
SO.
I'VE ALSO NOTICED.
THAT HE EXECUTIVES.
GET NICE RAISES.
THE PROFESSORS GET DECENT
RAISES.
ARE I I ACTUALLY THANK YOU BEEN
LEFT BEHIND ON THIS.
AND SO I'M GONNA GLADLY
SUPPORTED AND WE CAN JUST FIND
WAYS TO.
TO PAY FOR IT BECAUSE IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
MS BAKER.
I THINK I JUST HAD BECAUSE SOME
OF THE ISSUES OF COME UP LIKE
I'VE HAD A COUPLE QUESTIONS.
AT WERE EITHER FIRST SEE AS YOU
WERE. AT THE AUTHOR.
HOW FREQUENT ARE THE
EVALUATIONS?
AND THE PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO
GET A THUMBS UP.
THAT SOMETIMES A CRITICISM OF
STEPPING COLUMN IS THE RIGOR OF
THE EVALUATION PROCESS.
IT IS IT AND IT AND THE
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO GET IT
IF IT BECOMES I'M NOT SAYING
IT'S ON AUTO PILOT BUT IT'S
HELPFUL FOR ME TO KNOW A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT. HOW FREQUENT IF
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER? AND THE
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO GET THE
THUMBS UP OR.
IF IT IS THUMBS UP OR DOWN AND
AND I'VE I'VE WE APPRECIATE THAT
INFORMATION.
IT'S A IT'S A YEARLY EVALUATION.
GIVEN IN OCTOBER.
AND ME BEING THE THE CHIEF
STORED AT FRESNO STATE OCTOBER'S
VERY BUSY FOR ME. BECAUSE MOST
OF THE FOLKS THAT ARE CALLING ME
ARE CALLING BECAUSE OF.
UNSATISFACTORY PERFORMANCE
EVALUATION.
SO THEY ARE.
REGIMENTED THAT THEY ARE
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT PLANS
ARE CALLED PIPS
THAT ARE GIVEN TO THOSE
EMPLOYEES.
SO YES THEY ARE.
VERY STRICT WITH THOSE.
ACROSS THE BOARD BECAUSE THAT'S
MY BUSIEST MONTH AND THAT THE
CALLS PICK UP.
DRAMATICALLY IF THAT WAS THE
AYE IMPOSE THE FIVE PERCENT THAT
PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE RECOMMENDED
FOR THAT EMPLOYEE UNTIL TO
IMPROVE THEIR PERFORMANCE TO
MOVE TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
THANK YOU PAINT A PERCENTAGE
THAT YOU I'M NOT SURE HOW WHAT
WHAT'S UP WHAT DID THE UPPER
DOWN WOULD BE BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE STEP INCREASES RIGHT NOW SO
IT'S NOT LIKE EVALUATIONS A
LEADING YOU ON A STEP INCREASE
OF ANYTHING OF THAT NATURE I'M
NOT SURE. OF THAT.
I'D AS IT IS A CHAIR OF THE
DEPARTMENT I DID STAFF
EVALUATION FOR MY CLASSIFIED
STAFF AND I HAD TO DO THAT EVERY
YEAR. AND THEY WERE VERY
RIGOROUS IN TERMS OF NOT ONLY
LOOKING AT THE GOALS THAT HAD
BEEN SET AND WHAT YOU CAN
ACCOMPLISH DURING THAT TIME
FRAME AND IN SETTING NEW GOALS.
MUCH MORE RIGOROUS AND I SIGNED
IN MOST EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTES
IT'S QUE TWELFTH FOR INSTANCE IN
TERMS OF REALLY HAVING TO DO IT
EVERY IT WAS NOT OPTIONAL FOR ME
IS THAT YOU HAVE A DEPARTMENT. I
HAD TO DO THE EVALUATIONS I HAD
TO LOOK AT PAST EVALUATIONS HAD
TO SIT WITH THAT MEMBER AS OF
THAT STAFF MEMBER BUT CLERICAL
PERSONS AT MY OFFICE. AND GO
OVER THE VALUATIONS AND HAD TO
SIT DOWN AND HAVE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT FUTURE GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES.
AND THINGS THAT THEY NEED TO
WORK ON AND THOSE WHO DID MAKE
IT EVENTUALLY WERE GIVEN A
PLANNED FOR IMPROVEMENT AND
INFLATED IMPROVE BASICALLY WERE
TERMINATED FROM THE SYSTEM. SO
IT IS IT WOULD IT WAS TAKEN VERY
SERIOUSLY AND MY OFFICE BY BEING
EVEN WITH REGARDS EVALUATION AND
MY ASSUMPTION IS THAT WAS WITH
EVERYONE ELSE IS DOING THE SAME
THING BECAUSE THERE IS A TIME
FRAME. AND YOU DON'T HAVE THE
OPTION OF DOING IT OR NOT DOING
IT.
BUT WAS NOT TIED TO STEP
INCREASE BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE
THEM AT THAT TIME AFTER THEY GOT
RID OF THEM THEY WERE NOT THERE
UP BUT THEY'VE WE PRIOR TO A
CERTAIN PERIOD TIME THEY WERE
BUT. DIDN'T ALSO WANTS TO MISS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A
STATEMENT ABOUT FRESNO STATE.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW
FRESNO STATE WAS THE ONLY
COLLEGE THIS YEAR TO WIN A MAJOR
BOWL IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE SHOULD BE GRATEFUL.
THAT WE HAVE THE BULLDOGS AND
ARE ALL PROUD OF WHAT THEY ARE
SO.
THANK YOU FOR COMING TODAY.
I THOUGHT. I TO AM A PRESIDENT
STATE ROUTE AND APPRECIATIVE OF
THEIR SUCCESSFUL FILM BUT THEY
ALSO HAVE PRESIDENT CASTRO HAS.
SERIOUS SERIOUS NEEDS ON THE
CAMPUS INFRASTRUCTURE WISE. AND
EVERY DOLLAR THAT GETS PUT
TOWARD SALARIES A DOLLAR YOU
CANNOT USE FOR INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THAT IS ON OUR BUDGET FOR
NOW ON.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SO I I WILL THINK THE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR I THINK
VERY GOOD FRANK DISCUSSION.
I THINK.
THERE'S MUCH THAT I AGREE WITH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON.
MANY OF THE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAVEZ.
YOU KNOW APPRECIATING THE THE
WORK OF OF THE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES OF THE SUPPORT STAFF.
I I WAS A.
.
LONGTIME TEACHERS SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TRUSTEE.
YOU KNOW SCHOOLS DO NOT OPERATE
WHETHER THEY BE.
THE K. TWELVE OR CSU SYSTEM OR
THE UC SYSTEM. UP WITHOUT THE
SUPPORT STAFF OFTEN TIME THE
SUPPORT STAFF IS THE FIRST
PERSON THAT STUDENTS ME. WHETHER
THAT BE THE.
THE SECRETARY IN THE DEPARTMENT
OFFICE.
OR OR THE CUSTODIAN IN THE
DORMITORY.
AND SO THEY MAKE A DIFFERENCE SO
THE WORK THAT YOU DO MAKES A
DIFFERENCE AND I I SUPPORT
THOSE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHO
YOU KNOW WHO SAY THAT WE NEED TO
VALUE. THAT WORK AND WE NEED TO
VALUE THAT WORK BY DEMONSTRATING
THAT IN IN THE PACE SO I I
THANK.
SIMPLY MEMBER JOB IS FOR
BRINGING UP THOSE THINGS.
AS WELL AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON.
AND THEN ON THE OTHER HAND AS
WE HAVE SAID OFTENTIMES.
YOU KNOW WE CAN'T JUST SAY THAT
WE SUPPORT.
WHETHER IT BE THE CLASSIFIED
STAFF OR THE.
FACULTY AND THEN NOT GIVE GOOD
THE FUNDS TO THE.
TO THE SYSTEMS.
SO I I I SEE THE DILEMMA THAT
WE FACE.
I AM SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
HOWEVER BUT I WILL AGAIN REMIND
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THAT WE NEED TO VERY STRONGLY
VOICE OUR OPINION WHEN IT COMES
TO THE BUDGET.
AS WELL.
SO WITH THAT.
.
DO HAVE A MOTION.
ALRIGHT LOOK.
pBY MISTER SANTIAGO.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
.
MADAM SECRETARY RECALL THE ROLE.
MEDINA AYE AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER NO AROUND A LOT.
AROUND A LOT AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAVEZ.
SHOP AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO LEVINE.
LEVINE NO LOW. LOW AYE
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER AYE WEBER
AYE.
YEAH.
CHRIS IS A GREAT VOTE.
A VOTEIS TEN THREE YEAR
MEASURES OUT DOCTOR WEBER.
I THINK YOU MEMBERS.
IF IT'S NOT BIGGEST THE NEW FEW
PASTORS AYE.
BECAUSE I DO THIS IN THE ONE.
YEAH.
ALRIGHT.
WE HAVE THEM AB THREE TEN BY
CHAIR MEDINA.
ALTHOUGH WE'RE HAVING A GOOD
TIME HERE AT THE.
DIE AS WITH WHAT A GREAT BOOK
HAVE HUTCHES.
SO WILL.
THE.
CHAIRMAN EVERY READY BUT I MAY
TAKE A MOMENT TO JUST GET OUR.
JOYCE CONVERSATION OFF THE DíAS.
SO THAT WE CAN THAT. YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU.
I TRY TO BE BRIEF.
THANK YOU ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OVER TWO POINT ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS RISEN RELY ON A
WORKFORCE OF OVER FORTY
THOUSAND.
PART TIME FACULTY MEMBERS.
DESPITE THE GOAL THAT IS LONG
BEEN.
IN EDUCATION CODE OF TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT.
.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY
THREE POINT SIX OF ALL. CREDIT
CLASSES ARE BEING TAUGHT BY PART
TIME FACULTY.
WE WOULD NOT HAVE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IF IT WERE NOT FOR
THE PART TIME FACULTY.
THEY THEY THEY WOULD CLOSE DOWN.
THERE IS A DISTINCT RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE AFTER CLASSES ACCESS
TO FACULTY AND STUDENT SUCCESS.
BUT INFORMATION ON PART TIME
FACULTY OFFICE HOURS ARE NOT
REPORTED.
THIS BILL.
WOULD INCLUDE A REPORTING
REQUIREMENT ON THE AMOUNT OF
PART TIME FACULTY OFFICE HOURS
AT THE DISTRICT LEVEL.
AND WOULD REQUIRE THAT
INFORMATION BE PUBLICIZED ON
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
WEBSITES.
THE BILL ALSO SUPPORTS THE GOALS
OF THE STUDENT SUCCESS ACT
BY INCLUDING THE COLLECTIONS OF
METRICS CRITICAL FOR STUDENT
SUCCESS.
AS A TEACHER IS.
COMMUNICABLE EDGE TEACHER PART
TIME.
.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT FULL TIME.
OF FACULTY CAN DO WITH OFFICE
HOURS THAT PART TIME FACULTY
CANNOT.
THE PROJECTS
OR THE.
ASSIGNMENTS THAT YOU GIVE YOUR
STUDENTS.
THAT REQUIRE CONSULTATION WITH
THE STUDENTS REALLY CANNOT BE
DONE SUCCESSFULLY IF THERE ARE
NO OFFICE HOURS GIVEN TO PART
TIME FACULTY.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET OUTSIDE THE
CLASSROOM WITH THEIR STUDENTS
SO WITH THIS BILL IS ASKING IS
JUST THAT WE COLLECT THE DATA.
THAT WE COLLECT THE DATA AND
REPORT.
ON HOW THE DISTRICTS ARE DOING
AND GIVING OFFICE HOURS BUT TO
PART TIME FACULTY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YEAR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
AN ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITH WITH ME.
WITH HARRY IS A COURTNEY COOPER
PRESIDENT OF THE STUDENT SENATE
AND THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. AND JOHN GO LASKY PART
TIME FACULTY MEMBER ECHO BRIO
COLLEGE AND I HOPE I. PRONOUNCE
THAT CORRECTLY MORE LET'S THINK
IT.
THANK YOU.
LL SO. AS ESTATE AYE MY NAME IS
COURTNEY COOPER I AM A STUDENT
AT FOOTHILL COLLEGE AND THE
PRESIDENT THE STUDENTS IN A CULT
FOR INCOMMUNICADO AS WHICH
REPRESENTS THE TWO POINT ONE
MILLION TWENTY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
IN THE STATE AND THIS IS JUST A
VITALLY IMPORTANT BILL.
FOR ME I KNOW PERSONALLY AS A
STUDENT I HAVE HAD TO GO TO
DIFFERENT CITIES JUST TO GET
OFFICE HOURS WITH THE TEACHER I
HAVE HAD TO DRIVE OUT. AND I'M
LOOKING OF WHERE I NOW DRIVE
BIRD I KNOW FOR MY YOUNGER
BROTHER HE DOESN'T DRIVE AND HIS
DEMETER. AND THAT'S A THREE HOUR
BUS RIDE JUST IN BETWEEN OUR
HOME AND WHERE THE SCHOOL IS AND
AT LEAST A MAJOR IF HE DID NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO HIS PROFESSORS
FORGET THE CULTURES. THERE'S NO
WAY THAT HE WOULD BE SUCCESSFUL.
AND AS WE BOTH FOR FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH THAT COMPLETION RAISE ONLY
ABOUT THREE PERCENT FOR US FOR
MATRICULATION RATE SO. THIS IS
SOMETHING CRITICAL WHERE IF WE
COULDN'T PERHAPS THE ABILITY TO
GO ONLINE TO LOOK AT THE REPORT
CARD FOR SCHOOL AND NO. TRULY
WHAT ARE WE GET OURSELVES INTO
DO WE HAVE SUPPORT FROM OUR PART
TIME FACULTY WHEN WHERE WHEN
WERE ON THESE CAMPUSES. I THINK
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO ALLOW
STUDENTS TO MAKE THOSE INFORMED
DECISIONS BECAUSE IT'S ONE OF
THOSE HIDDEN COST OF GOING TO
COMMUNICATE WHICH.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL INCIDENTS
PART.
PLEASE THANK YOU UP MY NAME IS
JOHN GOV SKI AND I'M A PART TIME
INSTRUCTOR CAMINO COLLEGE HAVE
TAUGHT THERE FOR ABOUT TWENTY
SOME YEARS.
AS AN ADJUNCT AND.
THIS ISSUE IS REALLY IMPORTANT
ACCESS TO PROFESSORS IS PART OF
ITS IT'S AN INTEGRAL PART OF THE
JOB OF STUDENT SUCCESS OF WHAT A
STUDENT NEEDS TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
AND IT'S REALLY HARD FOR ME NOT
TO AT THAT TO UNDERSTAND WHY WE
DON'T HAVE A OFFICE HOURS FOR
ALL INSTRUCTORS IN THE CLINICAL
SYSTEM.
I'M LUCKY BECAUSE IT CAMINO
COLLEGE WE DO PAY OUR PARTS AND
INSTRUCTORS TO HOLD APPROPRIATE
OFFICE HOURS BUT AT. SOMETHING
LIKE A TWENTY SOME PERCENT OF
THE DISTRICTS THEY DO NOT PAY
PART TIME FACULTY TO HOLD OFFICE
HOURS THERE A COUPLE DISTRICTS
THAT PAY SOMETHING RIDICULOUS
LIKE. ONE HOUR PER SEMESTER PER
CLASS THERE ARE OF SEVERAL
DISTRICTS THAT DON'T PAY IF THEY
DON'T GET ENOUGH MONEY FROM THE
STATE SOMETIMES THEY DO TO.
THOSE
DID YOU SEE FUNDS AND IT REALLY
SHOULDN'T BE THE LUCK OF THE
DRAW WHETHER STUDENT HAS ACCESS
TO THE PROFESSOR NOT IT'S KIND
OF LOW HANGING STUDENT SUCCESS
FRUIT IN MY OPINION. OF THE
STATE THROWS A LOT OF MONEY AT
THESE INITIATIVES GUIDED
PATHWAYS TO SUCCESS AND THAT'S
REALLY GOOD AND THEY DO REALLY
GOOD THINGS.
BUT THE LOW HANGING FRUIT SCENE
SUCCESS IS REALLY ACCESSED YOUR
PROFESSOR SO I DON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHY THIS MORE BASIC
ASPECT OF STUDENT SUCCESS IS
KIND OF IGNORED AT THE STATE
LEVEL. ARE AND IT'S NOT A SEXY
INITIATIVE YOU KNOW IF WE CALL
IT. A PART TIME OFFICE HOURS FOR
STUDENT SUCCESS AND GUIDE
PATHWAYS MAYBE YOU GUYS WOULD.
HELP A LITTLE MORE I DON'T KNOW
BUT IT IT RELEASE FLABBERGASTING
TO ME AS TO WHY STUDENTS SHOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO GET ACCESS TO
PROFESSORS ACROSS THE SYSTEM
IT'S IT'S VITAL.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN HOW CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS WERE AS PART THAT
GIVES.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COLLEAGUES.
MISTER JARVI.
I'M.
SO REMEMBER MEDIAN I REALLY
APPRECIATE BIGGEST FOR A MEMBER
I WAS LOOKING AT THE GOVERNOR'S
VETO MESSAGE.
AND ESSENTIALLY THIS BILL HASN'T
CHANGED ALL.
.
HOW YOU GONNA DRESS IS CONCERNED
ABOUT TEN PERCENT?
OF THE TOTAL COSTS GOING THERE
WOULD GOING TO MANAGEMENT
REQUESTED TO DO WHAT YOU'RE
DOING.
AND WHICH AS HE SAYS IN THIS
PASSAGE.
WOOD TAKES WAY MONEY THAT WOULD
BE GOING TO HELP OUT STUDENTS
SINFUL AND PART TIME FACULTY SO.
WHAT SURE? WAY RESPONDING TO HIS
VETO MESSAGE.
I NEVER GIVE UP HOPE.
WELL HOPE TO WONDERFUL THING
WHAT'S THE PLAN.
IN THE END I AND I SAY THAT
ACTUALLY.
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AYE INSINCERITY.
SO WE'VE WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE
ARE MANY MEASURES THAT HAVE BEEN
PASSED BY THIS HOUSE.
BY THE LEGISLATURE.
.
THAT HAVE TAKEN MANY ATTEMPTS.
YOU NO ONE THAT COMES MOST
READILY QUICKLY TO MINE. IS A
THE DRIVER'S LICENSE.
AND I KNOW THAT OUR PREDECESSOR
HERE. YOU KNOW I THINK OVER FIVE
DIFFERENT TIMES INTRODUCED THAT
BILL ONLY TO HAVE IT VETOED.
THAT TIME AFTER TIME.
AND SO PERSISTENCE R. IS WORTH
SOMETHING.
AND.
WHEN SOMETHING IS NEEDED.
WE DON'T GIVE UP.
AND I THINK THIS IS MUCH NEEDED.
SO TWO THINGS TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION.
I I THINK THAT THE.
COST CONCERNS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
.
ARE.
HA EXAGGERATED.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE COST.
IS WHAT HE SAYS IT IS.
SO I I THINK THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
THE COST.
ONE.
AND TO.
.
I WILL BE HAVING A FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO LOOK FOR.
ALSO COSTS A.
SAVING MEASURES THAT WE CAN DO
AND IMPLEMENTING THIS BILL.
SO.
.
WITH THOSE TWO THINGS.
JARVIS I HOPE TO HAVE BETTER
LUCK.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COLLEAGUES AS
WEBER. AYE DISCIPLINE ONE I
THINK GO FOR HER CHEER FOR FOR
ONCE AGAIN BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I KNOW AT SOME.
A IT'S A DIFFICULT.
.
CHALLENGE ALWAYS A CONFLICT COME
BACK WITH THINGS OVER. BUT YOU
ALWAYS TWEAK THEM IN HOPES THAT
SOMEONE OTHER THAT IT IT IT GETS
ACROSS.
YOU'LL HAVE OFFICE HOURS ARE AT
ME OFTENTIMES PEOPLE WOULD NOT
AN INSTANT IN THE INSTITUTION
ITSELF.
I DON'T ALWAYS UNDERSTAND WHY
OFFICE HOURS ARE IMPORTANT AND
SOME OF MY FRIENDS WHO WORK OR
AT THE UNIVERSITY WOULD ALWAYS
WONDER WHAT'LL I DO THE REST OF
THE DAY. AFTER I SPENT.
SEVEN EIGHT HOURS TEACHING YOU
KNOW AB FOR THE WEEK WHAT DO I
DO WITH ALL THIS OF THE TIME.
RESEARCH AND THINGS LIKE THAT
THAT IMPORTANT. BUT ALL BUT MOST
IMPORTANT MEETING WITH STUDENTS
I MEAN THAT IS CRITICAL OF IT
YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHICH
SOMETIMES. MORE THAN THAT THE
OTHER CAMPUSES BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WHAT I FOUND IS THAT MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS WHO AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL ARE THE ONES WHO
PROBABLY NEED THE GREATEST
AMOUNT OF. GUIDANCE AND TOUCHING
AND FOLKS BASICALLY HELPING THEM
TO GET THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
ENCOURAGING THEM TO REMAIN THERE
WERE OTHERS MAY HAVE COME WITH
THE SPECIFIC MISSION IN MIND
THAT A BE AEROSPACE UP ANOTHER
WHATEVER. AND AND SO THE
ASSISTANCE THEY SEEK MAYBE NOT
ONLY JUST TECHNICAL ABOUT WHAT
THE STUFF IS WRITTEN A BOOK BUT
I OFTENTIMES AT THE AT THE AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL
BECAUSE YOU HAVE STUDENTS
ENTERING. WHO SOMETIMES ARE NOT
REAL CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THEY WANT
TO DO? WHO?
ARE NOT SURE HOW ALL OF THE
STUFF THEY'VE LEARNED FITS
TOGETHER IN A PATTERN OF SOME
SORT. AND I REALLY MAY BE COMING
OUT ENVIRONMENT WHERE HIGHER IT
IS NOT A.
AND SO YOU HAVE THE STUDENTS
THERE WHO REALLY NEED TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION.
WITH.
WITH WITH INDIVIDUALS ABOUT WHY
THEY'RE IN SCHOOL AND WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND HOW THIS FITS
TOGETHER. AND MANY STUDENTS AB
THAT EVENTUALLY MADE IT TO THE
UNIVERSITY TO SENEGAL STATE.
WOULD OFTEN TELL ME THAT THE
REASON WHY THEY WERE SUCCESSFUL
AFTER TWO OR THREE YEARS OF
TRYING TO FIGURE IT ALL OUT. WAS
BECAUSE OF DOCTOR SO AND SO IS
DOCTOR STARLAND LEWIS SO WHOEVER
IT WAS AT THAT TIME AT THEIR
COMMUNICABLE AS. THE STATE IN
TOUCH WITH THEM THAT ENCOURAGED
HIM TO DO SOMETHING THAT KEPT
THEM FOCUSED.
AND I KNOW WE'VE PUT A BIG PRICE
OR BIG IDEA ON HAVING STUDENTS
INTO THE INSTITUTION IN GRADUATE
IN A REASONABLE AMOUNT OF TIME.
A AND AND THAT'S A BIG PRIORITY
AT THIS CAPITA WE'VE SAID THAT.
WE'VE ALSO SAID THE CENTRAL TO
THAT IS MENTORING.
AND COUNSELING.
AND OFTEN TIMES COUNSELING IS
NOT IN THE COUNSELING CENTER.
BUT IN THE CLASSROOM.
OR OUTSIDE THE CLASSROOM WITH
THAT PARTICULAR FACULTY MEMBER
AND SO MANY STUDENTS HAVE NEVER
SEEN IT A CAMPUS COUNSELOR. BUT
THEY HAVE SEEN THEIR PROFESSOR.
THEY'VE SEEN THE PERSON IN THE
CLASSROOM SO I THINK WE HAVE TO
KEEP PUSHING THIS BECAUSE IT IS
IT'S IT'S WHAT THE INSTITUTIONS
DO AND SOMETIMES PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT. THAT IS MORE
THAN THE HOUR A DAY IN CLASS
WITH THE PROFESSOR IT'S
OFTENTIMES OUTSIDE EXPERIENCE IN
THE CONVERSATION THAT MOTIVATES
AT STUDENTS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
TO DO THE JOB TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY'RE DOING. AND TO BECOME
SUCCESSFUL
AND.
AND SO I APPRECIATE THAT AND WE
HAVE TO KEEP PUSHING THESE
ISSUES THAT IMPORTANT. WE HAVE
GONE THROUGH A PROCESS AT LEAST
IT OVER THE LAST TEN TWELVE
YEARS WE HAVE JUST DRAMATICALLY
ALTER R. C. ISSUES AND I UC'S IN
TERMS OF. WHAT THEIR CULTURE IS
ALL ABOUT AND HOW THEY OPERATE
AND HOW THEY DEAL WITH STUDENTS
IN THOSE KINDS OF THINGS UNDER
UNDER DIFFICULT TIME TO DO THAT?
TIMES ARE BETTER.
AND WE SHOULD BE DOING BETTER.
INSIDE THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
YOU CHAIRED LIKE CLOSE.
ESPECIALLY AS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AT THIS IS A DO YOU
PASS TWO PROBES I'M PLEASE TO
SUPPORT IT AGAIN AND I THINK I
GOT UNANIMOUS SUPPORT LAST TIME.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA. AROUND A LOT
AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHáVEZ CHáVEZ AYE
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE. LEVINE AYE
LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
TWELVE ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
MISTER CHAIR.
AND THAT CONGRATULATIONS DO WE
HAVE THE ONE HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
EVERY. WE'RE GOOD TO HAVE ANY
ABSENT MEMBERS YOU HAVE IN A
MISTER SANTIAGO.
CANNELLA.
START WITH OUTLINES.
ITEM TO A BE EIGHT ZERO NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TWO PROBES.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE LIVING LEVINE AYE
LOW LOW AYE SANTIAGO.
TWELVE.
TWELVE ZERO WE CAN HOLD THAT ON
IF MR SANTIAGO IS COMING YET ANY
OTHERS.
JUST THAT ONE. OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU.
WE'RE GOOD.
AND WITH WITH SANTIAGO.
YEAH YEAH BROKE.
THANK YOU.
WERE YOU
ITEM ONE A. B. THREE TEN.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
THE VOTE IS.
THIRTEEN ZERO EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO
NINE.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE VOTES THIRTEEN
ZERO.
OKAY.
WHERE YOU'RE